you
mark fields heightened great welcome to
the industrialists dilemma so I think
just to kick things off if you want to
we just heard from obviously a lot of
kind of the the class around different
thoughts around where you guys should
take the company and what you guys
should be doing maybe you could step
back and share a little about the state
of the auto industry and the
transportation industry and then segue
into where where you see Ford going
through all of that now well first off I
want to start with that question what
keeps me up at night
I am so tired by the end of the night I
sleep great there's nothing that keeps
me and first off the air the the level
of discussion and all the topics that
you brought up are really spot on
there's anything that keeps you up you
know the one thing you did miss is the
culture the people you know in any
business whether you're a manufacturing
business you're a service business etc
it's about the culture and the people
and you need to make sure that you have
a culture that actually is going to be
able to execute this strategy because
that is that that that that famous
saying culture eats strategy for
breakfast and you should never forget
that's the only thing you miss but as
you look at the auto industry right now
it is I think we are at the most
transformational time in the auto
industry than we've seen in over a
hundred years and the reason for that is
because when you look at the enabling
technologies that are available to the
industry today than there ever there
have been even in the last 67 years it's
it's pretty transformational but it's
not just that the technology that's
changing it because we always tend to
focus on the thing right the technology
or the product or whatever but it gets
back to people right and when you look
at the societal factors that are out
there they're huge and you know every
business needs to think about what the
world is going to look like 10 15 20
years from now so we spent a lot of time
looking at those societal factors and
you look at the growth of mega cities
around the world 10 million or more
people there's like 28 today it's going
to go to over 40 in 15 years when you
look at the growth of the
middle-class it's going to double in the
next 15 years and of course what's the
first thing somebody wants to do when
they get into the middle class let's go
buy a car so that's even more congestion
you look at air quality right around the
world it used to be a discussion around
impact to the environment and that's
still very true but it's also an impact
to just basic health all right you've
seen the pictures of some of these
cities where everybody is walking around
with the surgical masks you know telling
their kids they they can't go out or you
the you know elderly folks can't go down
and go grocery shopping because they
can't breathe and then finally just
changing consumer habits Millennials
right all of you a lot of you like
access versus ownership so we're looking
at all that stuff and understanding what
does that mean for our business and as
we go forward I think what you're going
to see is particularly in urban areas
there's going to be less vehicle density
right that has implications for our
business there's going to be
opportunities for how do you provide
mobility in an area where there's less
vehicle densities what does that mean
for our business so when you look at
that but then also there's the other
parts of the world and and you know for
many years in our lifetimes and I think
you know we will all be probably long
and buried after people will still
continue to buy and drive vehicles the
way they've had for many many years you
know in rural areas in X urban areas etc
and it's really important to keep both
of those things in your head at the same
time because it has implications for
your core business but also where you're
heading so in the future you're going to
see an industry that is going to deal
with those issues you're going to see an
industry where vehicles are going to
become more more capable more predictive
more intuitive running the gamut from
people that want fun to drive but also
people that just want fun to ride right
whether you're in a service etc so when
you look at that and when you look at
the competitive landscape going forward
there will be I think a lot of the
traditional players and Ford will be one
of them of course but also there's going
to the barriers to entry
into this business have come down right
3d printing
you know distribution models that are
different etc and so I think you you
will see competitors in this space that
you've never seen before and you will
see more and more folks that will try
and challenge custom and questioned
tradition so it's a really exciting
place and overall what you'll see is
continued growth in the auto industry
you know when you look at the emerging
markets you know the China's the India's
the Thailand's the Indonesia's etc I
mean we are still in a growth industry
around the world
and so that's that's the way we view how
would you let's say in five years from
now what would the sentence or paragraph
or whatever be that anybody would use to
describe Ford as a company Ford is an
auto and a mobility company we are in
this trans transition right now and it's
really important because of those
societal factors I mentioned but
mobility for us first off you have to
link and it get back gets back to
culture and people you have to link a
mission for folks right it's not about
coming in and you know designing the
next widget etc and it always comes down
to what is the why of your company the
why of our company going back to our
founder is making people's lives better
Henry Ford the reason he started a car
company is because he wanted to figure
out a way to democratize this technology
that was only available for rich people
and he gave the ability for people to
actually travel three miles outside of
where they were born because most people
lived believe it or not within three
miles they never went out he gave them
that opportunity
economic development etc so ry has
always been about making people's lives
better and our how is about how do we
enable mobility and for us mobility is
just allowing people to live play and
work where they want right and so as we
move from you already mentioned sort of
some of this being on-demand some of it
being about access and some of it being
writing versus driving as we move to a
world where potentially transportation
of abilities delivered more of the
service that's obviously a very
different world
and transportation mobility delivered as
a product that I buy how how do you sort
of prepare forward for that and what are
the sort of fundamental changes in your
business model and your in your company
DNA and your talent that kind of lead to
you guys being able to drive that well
the way you prepare the organization
this is a really important piece you
know how do you how do you rewire the
house while electricity is on right with
your with your business and the way
we're thinking about this is we have our
core business designing and developing
and manufacturing great cars and trucks
and we have these emerging opportunities
around mobility and its really a lot of
it around the monetization of the use of
our product and the most important thing
of how you prepare the organization is
you give the organization context you
have to be out there you have to be
communicating it you have to be linking
it to how customers and society is
changing because guess what if you don't
and you introduce these new businesses
there's new business models around
mobility and you know as we do let's say
we want to do transportation as a
service etc guess what if you don't give
the organization context they're going
to view that is oh that's all that new
stuff I'm not going to help them right
because that's that's a threat to to the
core business so you have to it has to
be an aunt solution what you have to be
able to tell people is we're not moving
from an old business to a new business
we're just moving to a bigger business
and when you get that context because we
have in our history where we've tried to
go off and go off to shiny sexy new
things guess what
didn't work because we didn't give the
organization context and oh by the way
the people that weren't in that Chinese
sexy new thing they felt that they were
chopped liver
right you know just do that core stuff
and you won't be valued so it's really
important that we do that and that's how
we prepare the organization and then you
can go off and you can dedicate
resources to it you can bring in new
competencies and new people you can do
ma that will then be embraced by the
organization so that you can build the
business and how should we think about
Ford's role in transportation as a
service in kind of your words where when
can i download the Ford app press the
button and have a car come to me
well actually what you'll be able to do
we are actually are launching something
in April code called Ford pass and it's
it's it's basically our what we want to
do there is
be able to do what we want that to do to
the auto industry what iTunes did for
the music industry so we'll have an app
it's powered through an app and it's
it's a it's a set of digital and
physical experiences so that you can you
can survey get make appointments for
your dealership but also at the same
time we're working with partners to do
smart parking so let's say you're
outside you want to come down to
downtown Palo Alto you'll be able to
reserve a parking space through it etc
and we're going to build that over time
so we have an ongoing relationship with
our customer but what's going to happen
you will be able to do that you know
we'll still have our core business but
we'll also in this mobility space we are
working on things like autonomous
vehicles we are working on you know
should we be in a transportation as a
service should you be taking on the
ubers etc but also remember in business
it's it's all about also are you
differentiated and relevant so for
example we have a big strong truck
business around the world hmm are there
some opportunities for us on an
on-demand service for commercial
vehicles you know how do you deliver at
that last mile in a crowded city center
those are the type of things that we're
thinking about why didn't do it excuse
me you do it we are thinking about those
things very seriously right now okay so
Marc is the requirements to meet
customer needs change how do you look at
external partnerships you've got a
presence in Silicon Valley how do you
ensure that Ford is not one of these
large companies from the outside who
comes in and sets up a presence here for
five to seven years and then bolts
Canton leaves that's a great it's a it's
a really great question how we view
partnerships we have been very very
clear the last night I'm sucking up to
the professor
okay so it's really good to be back in
class you know the difference at Harvard
we had no windows so first off as it
pertains to partnerships we have said
listen in some cases we will do things
on our own we will decide these things
are core for us in other cases we will
decide we're going to partner with
others and you know what that's okay and
as you think about you know Silicon
Valley we have decided and we set up
shop here a year ago we are building out
a very large we have one of the largest
research and innovation centers here now
in Silicon Valley and the reason we want
to do is to your point we didn't want to
be viewed as some transactional company
that flies in says I'll take one of
those I'll take one of these and flies
out and tells the organization to figure
out how to do it we want to be part of
the community we want to be rubbing up
against different people and companies
and generating ideas and and just being
viewed as part of the whole ecosystem
here so as we go forward in some cases
we will partner and really interestingly
when you look at the technology business
look at some of the tech players they
are fierce competitors in some segments
but in other areas they work together my
view going forward in the in the auto
industry and for us in particular you
could view that you can see that future
do you have a framework for how you
decide what is going to be core in the
future versus what you are going to
partner for is it is it based on like
what you know where the margin is going
to be is it based on what you think a
strategic control point might be is it
based on you know a data asset how do
you decide what is what is going to be
core versus you know context well first
off we have to dimension what we think
the opportunity is right we talked about
data right so we who owns the data for
example we have to take a point of view
on that says what can you do with that
data and then what are the opportunities
what do we think the the revenue pools
are that are out there and then kind of
link back and say gee maybe we want to
be core in these two or three areas and
then we have to ourselves ask ourselves
the next question saying can we do it
better than others and if the answer is
yes we can but we're going to have to
add resources to our company bring in
new talent that's one thing and
and but in other cases we may say you
know what not worth the trip there are
other companies that do this 24/7 and
from a return on investment standpoint
probably not the right thing to do what
on when you think about the the
traditional set of partners though that
you have the industry for I don't know
what you'd say 20 30 50 years has sort
of evolved to support the current user
industrial centric automotive industry
and so you have a bunch of existing
partners some of those are the
dealership network some of those are
manufacturing partners how do you decide
when you're going to work with them to
evolve them into the future versus times
where you might need to be more
disruptive and do something yourself
that you use to partner for because
that's the only way you're going to be
able to create the sort of modern
integrated solution we look at it the
following way first off our approach is
how do we disrupt ourselves before
others do and that's a really important
statement to make within the company and
secondly the second most important two
questions that we challenge the
organization with is how do we challenge
custom and questioned tradition and not
take anything for granted and when you
give the organization the permission
particularly in 113 year old company to
actually ask that wonderful things
happen in terms of creativity so when
you look at the the issue of you know do
we want to work with a specific supplier
who we work with for many years on a
specific technology from our standpoint
when we ask those two questions and we
get back to hmm do we want to as we look
at the opportunity or do we want to give
that margin up to somebody else or do we
want to make a core for ourselves and
those are the type of questions that
we're asking and we also have to be very
honest with ourselves that say that says
listen as the world changes
relationships are important but at the
end of the day you also have to look at
the business logic of continuing to work
with others that you work with for so
long and then make make very rational
decisions if you said this is the
biggest change you've ever seen in the
auto industry how do you as the CEO of
the business determine where to spend
your time
I drink a lot of Red Bull okay the
question on how much do I spend on my
time it's very interesting do you act
might yeah I drink a real great cool
okay can't you tell you I spend fifty
percent of my time on today's business
one foot and today and fifty percent of
my time one foot in tomorrow and the
reason I do that is a couple of fold one
as the CEO one of my prime roles is to
make sure that we deliver this month
sales and this quarters financials and
this year's objectives etc at the same
time the other part of my role is trying
to look at the outside world and look at
some of those societal factors other
factors and try and interpret that what
does that mean for us and then bring my
management team together that says ok
let's get a point of view on that future
and then craft a strategy that says
here's what here's where we want to play
and how we want to play and rewind back
to today and make sure we're starting to
make those decisions and plans in place
to give us the maximum chance of success
in that world that we see but the the
reason I spend 50% of time of my time in
today is you can never get disconnected
from the business any CEO that spends
all their time thinking about 15 years
from now starts not only getting
disconnected from the business today
they start getting disconnected from
what are the trends that they're seeing
right whether it's customers or in the
market or with governments etc and you
really need to get used to keep yourself
hardwired in that one foot in today and
one foot in tomorrow what do you think
that the you know you have that existing
set of competitors for the current 50%
of your business do you see the Ford
strategy is being differentiated
relative to let's say the GM's and the
BMWs of the world in some particularly
unique way or do you think that everyone
is sort of going to that same transition
together and it's all about sort how do
we grow the total pie for this industry
well we in in the industry itself in any
industry you have to be differentiated
and relevant right and you know our
brand I know there
a little bit discussion around the brand
are we have a huge advantage around the
world we have one brand it's the Ford
oval and in many many places across the
world we have been known as a brand that
is accessible it's it's it's in jus
ingenuity and it has a human factor to
it right it was started by Henry Ford
the family still involved those type of
things and as we go forward you know
we're making choices on where do we want
to differentiate ourselves you look at
we talk about our truck franchise that
is something that is very very important
to us when you look at for example the
other end of the extreme are performance
vehicles you know Mustangs Ford GTS
Focus RS those kind of things so we're
all trying to search for what is our
differentiated but relevant position but
I think ours is again a differentiated
position around making people's lives
better and allowing them to be mobile
and that's what we're going to be
focusing on gofal it wouldn't marry sort
of say something similar about Jam right
now you'd have to ask Mary okay
everybody will wean call afterwards but
on when when what if what if Tesla's
sort of significant advantages is I
think they've they've come up with how
do you integrate a couple different
kinds of DNA's into one organization and
this is where Tony Fadell and a couple
weeks ago
Tony's great guy yeah absolutely and
talking about how how you know nest is
it's hardware it's cloud it's software
but as you know for manufacturing that's
a very different process than you know
doing daily software releases how do you
deal with the fact that the future of
Transportation is going to have multiple
of these sort of work streams do you
have to kind of integrated them together
at the executive level do you have them
run separately and in parallel how do
you see sort of weaving all that
together well it's it's it's it's very
interesting because what we learned as
we were for example when we launched our
sink system back in 2007 and we were
working with Microsoft on that your your
what we learned is how do you deal with
two different clock speeds right because
the way we design develop and
manufacture vehicles it takes literally
four years between you know design to
actually getting it out on the road and
so what we have to do at the executive
we have to be really tightly linked at
the executive level on how to integrate
these things and understand what the
nuances are and the differences are and
then what you need to make sure is the
way you run the business you have your
skill teams let's say product
development finance purchasing etc you
need to make sure that you have a
process where there's a lot of
cross-functional fertilization between
the groups because it all we are if you
think about a car right it's got over
four 4,000 5,000 6,000 parts now you
have software on top of it we are the
ultimate systems integrator right and
for those of you that that know that
particular that particular skill you
have really have to make sure that your
organization is very tightly linked and
you do that at the core of the business
or do you have this sort of kind of
Macintosh team iPhone team sort of
they're off in a corner they have hired
flag sort of waving above and they can
go you know you know build the
integrated car without any disruption
the way let me just describe how we're
approaching the core business and also
these emerging opportunities we've had a
lot of discussion around this because if
you just have let's say that though the
emerging opportunities what we call Ford
smart mobility which is basically our
approach in our strategy to be a leader
in connectivity mobility autonomous
vehicles data and analytics if you have
that group on Mars and you're on Venus
it's going to fail because you mately a
lot of the things that you need to be
successful in that mobility area depends
on making sure you have good vehicles to
do that and so you get a service level
agreement between the two organizations
we you can but you'll make one plus one
equal two and a half or one plus one
equal one and a half and thus better
instead of taking one plus one equal
three and so it has to be separate
enough so it's not encumbered by the
bureaucracy that process all those kind
of things but you can't make it so
separate that it's completely
disconnected and the two can't they
can't rub off of each other and come up
with even more ideas that add value
to the company right what core
competency does Ford not have in house
today or is just starting that you think
is critical for the next five to ten
years that you need to develop in-house
and make it your own I think there's two
that we're starting to build now in a
fairly large way one is we talked a lot
about data and analytics and we have
about two years ago I decided to make
sure that we had all these great pockets
of analytics in the company I wanted to
kind of bring them all together and and
named a leader to that and then grow it
substantially because I strongly believe
when I joined the company long time ago
we're a manufacturing company today
we're manufacturing in a technology
company tomorrow we're going to be those
things plus an information company right
as our vehicles become part of the
Internet of Things and of course a
mobility company so that's the first one
and then the second one is skills in
design design thinking right and what I
mean by that is free for many years in
the auto industry we tended to you know
have the headlight lamp engineer who is
separately designing that from the HVAC
kind of engineer and you had different
buttons and you got in the car you went
we noticed yeah what is it not recently
I'm going forward what I want our
engineers and our marketers and our
entire organizations thinking about is
the experience what experiences are we
creating today and then what is the
technology the hardware the software
that enables that and that Design
Thinking is a something that we're
investing heavily in and we're also kind
of our head of product development is
kind of turning really turning upside
down a whole approach to developing
vehicles based on that if you take an
experience point of view then the that's
everything from the the product itself
in the service itself to how do i how do
I get to it in the first place so how do
you think with the dealership network
and your channels of distribution as it
relates to creating this integrated
experience because certainly a Tesla
gets to own end to end right that entire
experience throughout all of our touch
all of those touch points and as was
mentioned earlier you know here in the
US with the franchise law
by law we cannot go direct to the
customers at the same time you know our
dealers we have 10,000 dealers around
the globe that is a huge advantage I
think somebody mentioned you know the
whole issue about having a distribution
network so the way we have to do this
first off as we go off on this journey
we have to bring our dealers with us and
we have to say what is your role as we
go forward right because you're good
partners for us and let's face it I know
there's talk about being a little bit of
a bubble here but you know let's face it
folks you know you're not going to hit
the the Buy button and then you know a
vehicle is going to show up people want
at your Patrick calls and from stripe
said you would be able to do that well
you first class there's there's a
difference between you could do it when
people do they want to do it right it's
the second biggest purchase year we're
going to make after your house right you
can buy your house online people want to
feel they want to touch yellow said well
no I chopped him I wish I wouldn't
visited him and he said that's a good
revenue opportunity for us but but bring
it first off it's also again it's about
people and it's about giving the
organization context so we're spending a
lot of time with our dealers and saying
here is the way the world is changing
you have a choice do you want to work
with us right as because it's the
customer who's in charge not us do you
want to work with us and how do we
outfit the stores going forward I mean
somebody mentioned you know the stores
could be very different going forward
and how do you bring them with us as
opposed to we're going to do it
separately and we're going to break the
law and we're going to create World War
3 with our distribution network that is
a recipe for disaster what I what do you
just just out of curiosity what do you
see their role being then in five or ten
years when we're throwing the sort of
mobility on demand kind of world well
again you're making big assumptions here
we're gonna do it 20 years from now
right the world Rathod the world is
going to be populated by these
autonomous roaming vehicles in any part
of the world you'll hit your smartphone
bone smart your button on your smart
phone or your iPhone it's going to show
up guys it's a speck
right there's going to be people that
are going to be driving vehicles they've
had for many years yes there will be a
growing segment of that so you know
their role our dealers role going
forward will be continuing right to take
care of the customer right to sell them
vehicles when they want to buy vehicles
but also to service vehicles when they
have to as we think about transportation
as a service what role do they have
we're working working our way through
that but they will play a vital role you
know there's a look at Amazon right
they're creating retail you think about
this Amazon was born online right
what are they creating now stores
they're creating stores we have 10,000
dealers or stores around the world that
could be a huge advantage of course how
do you hire people with different DNA
into the organization and make sure that
they stay and don't come for 18 to 24
months and then decide to go back to
where they were before this is a really
important question because it's the war
listen it everybody heard the term name
the term war for talent you know the
best team wins all that kind of stuff so
how do you do it first off what you do
is you what you want to do is you want
people across every cohort but it's it's
it's a lot in the Millennials they want
to make a difference they want to make
their dent on the universe they they yes
they want to be compensated
appropriately etc they want to be at a
higher mission and our mission is a meet
make making people's lives better and
what better way of doing that is not
only developing great cars and trucks
going forward but helping solve some of
the world's most pressing societal
issues around mobility and then secondly
you you develop them and you also have
to have a realization like here in
Silicon Valley we used to be a company
if you didn't know eating if you decided
to leave Ford Motor Company after five
years you were excommunicated don't ever
bother coming back first off here we've
recognized a couple of things one is a
lot of people join companies here in
Silicon Valley they don't join companies
they
they join projects I get to get pension
and look if I have to five years they
ate their own projects so we have to be
comfortable as a company knowing that in
some cases we'll write people for a
while but at the same time we also want
to tell them you can come to Ford and go
from one project and do that for you
know a year 18 months where go to the
next project you can have a great career
at Ford I'm an example of that you know
I never I never joined forward thinking
you know one day I'm going to live in
four different countries and have all
these experiences I never thought I'd be
able to do the things I've been able to
do you know in my 27 years at Ford I
probably had eight careers and that is
something that we want to give people a
mission but also they can have a great
career forward and work on something
that they can point to not a not a line
of code and say I did that I was part of
that that's really important to folks
when as relates to Silicon Valley and
have Ford's relationship to it so GM
obviously recently invested in lifts you
you guys have there's been rumors about
big partnerships that you guys are doing
there's some announcements at CES how do
you think about the role of sort of
corporate venture capital in going into
startup so you see an opportunity right
now what kinds of companies would those
be
and then ultimately I guess if there's
anything you can share around what you
expect your relationship to be with a
Google I think there there's a lot of
curiosity around that well I think on
that last one there's you know lots of
speculation out there and what we've
said is less and we talk with everybody
and I spend you know our folks spend a
lot of time here I spend a lot of time
here I probably know you know all the
same people you do now in the tech space
and you know we we talk with someone we
work with some we just talk with and
obviously for competitive reasons we're
not going to you know I'm not going to
for you know talk about you know who
were doing things with for obviously for
confidentiality reasons but and so
there's there's an elegant way of that
question but it's like are you hanging
out more in Mountain View or like
Hey
I just like coming anywhere here it's
winter back in Detroit but when you so
what was the first question again first
question is are you going to investor a
venture venture uber you know I guess I
think you have to be very strategic
about those things I mean I would rather
be I'd rather be ahead than fast and
what I mean by that is when you think of
venture I think you have to link it
first back to what are those big bets
that you're taking as a company your
strategic big bets and we're going to
talk more about that as a company over
the next year or so you have to link it
back to that and then secondly on
venture I think you have to be careful
because if you decide to invest 10% in
you know company X or company Y and then
six months later you see a different
technology and you're like wow I'd
really like that but oh my gosh am I
kind of already have this investment
here I think you have to be really
careful about that
that's different from full M&A right
right as you see something you say hey
it's a core it's a competency I don't
have it's a skill set I don't have and
we realize we do want to make a core you
go out and and you integrate it into the
company so I think you have to be you
have to be careful and different strokes
for different folks depending upon the
company could we expect any of this from
for the series thank you oh you know
from our standpoint you will see us get
more aggressive around M&A well awesome
all right mark thanks a lot really